here's a video that went viral this week
thanks to um
libs of tick tock it's a woman
grooming her son live on camera and in a
department store dressing room know that
what appears to be a department store
dressing room no less uh let's
watch some of this
okay hold on you love it
and you want it and you picked it out
but you don't have to but you don't want
it for school can you tell me why
because last time i wore a dress to
school everybody called me a girl
oh
well what did we learn from my shadow is
pink
even when you wear a dress you're not a
girl
what makes a shirt for a boy or a girl
nothing
so do you want this you picked it out
i do want it you want to wear it all the
time at home but not at school right
yeah tell me about that i don't want to
get made fun of and that's what they
always do when i wear pink
stuff
i'm sorry not when i do it only on
special occasions
what makes you like dresses so much
i just like dresses
do you think bright pretty colors
and dresses and sequins and jewels and
golds all the things that you always
want to wear
do you think that's your innermost you
mm-hmm
it is well how are you going to be your
innermost you when we live in a place
that people think
clothing belongs to particular gender
it's a trick isn't it
you know your mommy gets made fun of by
people for looking like this too
what do you think about that
nope
that's not that's that's just wrong
what's the thing that always jumps out
at you when you watch when you see these
kinds of videos
of
parents grooming their kids
and filming it and then posting it
proudly and in this case
it's just made all the more disturbing
by the fact that she's in a dream she's
in the
dressing room at a department store and
she's filming
her own kid
so what jumps out of you well of course
just how how outrageously disgusting all
of this is right but but also what you
notice with the kid
like every time with these kinds of
videos and unfortunately there are many
videos like this
so the kid doesn't
is not engaged okay he's just a kid
i'm not sure how old this kid looks like
he's uh four maybe
four or five or so you know around there
and like any four or five-year-old kid
he's not he's just being a kid he's just
kind of bouncing around and and she's
she's interrogating him
trying to get him to say the lines that
she's fed him so that she can get it on
camera and post it on tiktok and get you
know and and be congratulated for it
but the kid's not even really
cooperating because uh he's just a kid
he doesn't care about this
like he actually
does not have any intense desire to wear
dresses
she's asking well why do you want to
wear a dress oh no
he doesn't care like you could easily
no even if the if the boy did have some
intense desire to wear dresses as the
parent you still say no
and if the desire's that intense you
know there's something psychologically
going on you get them some counseling
right if that's what it comes to but but
the point is in in like 99 of cases it
wouldn't even be
necessary yeah that that that the child
may have maybe
at some point in the past expressed some
kind of desire to wear a dress to school
or something
i'm skeptical of that i mean it seems
apparent to me that she's been feeding
all of this to him from the beginning
but let's just say
that at some point a year ago you know
he said my own dress i want to wear a
dress at school
well it's really obvious in that video
that you could just say to the kid
uh oh no no boys don't wear that just
wear this instead and he'd be fine with
it so he doesn't care that much of
course he doesn't
okay breaking down gender barriers and
uh destroying the binary and all that
stuff no kid understands any of that or
cares about it that's not their priority
in life
this kid's bouncing off the walls he
just wants to go outside and play and be
a boy that's all he wants
okay leave the dressing room
this is for the mom leave the dressing
room put the camera down you freak
you child abusing freak
bring your kid to a playground
and let him climb on the jungle gym
because that's all he wants to do
he doesn't want to be a part of this
but he also doesn't because because
unfortunately he's stuck with you and he
has no other frame of reference he
doesn't understand what's happening to
him
and he can't communicate
that he just wants you to shut the hell
up and let him live his life as a boy
from every single video like this
and this includes all the you know the
documentaries and reality shows they've
done
i am jazz whatever that hbo documentary
was last year
about the quote-unquote trans kids and
all of those things when if you actually
watch and it's it's hard to stomach
watching any of it but it can be quite
instructive to watch a little bit of it
because this is what you always find is
that these young kids they they don't
care they're not invested in this what
is allegedly their innermost identity
and if they weren't allowed to express
it they would be in in despair
and you actually see it in real time and
of course they just they just don't care
they just want they just let them go
outside and play that's all they want to
do
stop stop
imposing
[Music]
all of your
delusions and hang-ups and everything
and your ideology and all this stuff
and
hanging it around your
child's neck and forcing him to wear it
around well i hope you enjoyed that clip
for the matte wall show if you did go
ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content